- - for next caller is from the - - for
area code go ahead hey David you Spanish
oh thank you you hear me I can hear fine
yeah okay I was watching on your
intellectual dark web videos lately and
uh I you might have said this but uh I
was wondering if you thought that the
huge like obsession with people in the
intellectual dark web is mainly a
problem with a certain age group like
high school kids college kids and maybe
a little after that or it's basically
anyone of any age I don't have data on
that but my guess is that it's not sixty
five year olds who are thinking that you
know Jordan Peterson and Dave Rubin are
the answers to society's problems that
that's my sense I do think that it is a
younger crowd I think just anecdotally
if you look at the crowds from some of
the events that these people do and
people like Ben Shapiro I think it is
mostly younger people disproportionately
younger people but I don't have any data
on that yeah so could I ask you just
another quick question yeah the last
call sure okay um
cuz I know that there's a lot people
that love to throw around like the race
and IQ difference and and like the
identity politics right but whenever you
try and like look up statistics on it it
doesn't seem like I don't know if you
could really call it like scientific
evidence cuz it doesn't seem like the
stats are really like like like like
true you're saying let me see let me
just make sure I know what you're saying
are you saying that there's not actually
that much support for the idea that
black people are inherently less
intelligent or that identity politics is
the way to do politics or are you saying
that the assertions people are making
about those things aren't true
oh I'm saying no I'm saying they have a
lot of support it seems like you're not
saying to me I was just saying you're
just saying they're assertions aren't
true yeah I'm just saying that I don't
agree with
like they're saying that like race and
IQ thing is like scientifically proven
but I don't think that the evidence that
they give for it is complete like
evidence I agree with the work I do yeah
I mean listen it's with the race and IQ
thing it's much more complicated than
this but if we wanted to still it down
it's people mistaking a correlation for
a causation but that's what we have a
correlational relationship that is being
attributed I believe in bad faith as a
causal relationship and it I know it's
more complicated than that but that's a
simple way to explain it yeah all right
thank you really appreciate the call
important issues all very important
issues sorry to everybody I didn't get
to we will take calls again next week
quick break back after this